to have a mural i mean that's my wildest
dream
i don't think it's enough for athletes
to
play in their cities and just be like
you know i'll wear the city's name
across my chest but i won't give back to
it no like i'm a part of this community
and i need to do what i can to make sure
that we're progressing this community
forward so everything i do
with social reform i try to incorporate
dc so when i say i love this city i love
this city
[Music]
we're using the vehicle basketball uh to
help get them a college education what's
going to help them go on to be future
ceos doctors we're preparing them for
life everything is about education
and we're just using basketball as the
two
[Music]
[Applause]
you know she's supporting black lives
not only but also women being a part of
something so powerful and so moving it's
like really inspiring we're so happy
that zell and bleacher report is here at
our school
and taking advantage of this opportunity
to celebrate women
[Applause]
how y'all doing today very good
no i've been in this community for seven
years i've been an underdog all my life
so i have a lot of pride in my journey
and what it took to get to here where
i'm at today i know that i matter to
y'all because i know who mattered to me
when i was growing up representation
matters and i want you all to see
yourselves and me and know that whatever
dream you aspire to you are capable of
doing it you can be a lawyer a doctor
whatever it may be you all need to be
able to see yourselves in those
different lights and it's huge for me to
give back to this community i love dc
like it's a home for me and doing what i
can for the community using this
god-given platform
i feel tremendously blessed that we've
had some great athletes come through
here we're just super excited about you
know the future and certainly you know
very very proud of the legacy that we
feel
so coach i heard y'all are doing some
fundraising how's that going for you uh
could be going better of course you know
we're
proud to be a nationally ranked program
and we raised the money to get to the
nike tournament champions and uh we're
opening up our season this year in san
juan puerto rico yes sir absolutely okay
on behalf of highlight her and zell we
want to give you a portion of your
fundraising so we're sending you money
with zelle which should be in your bank
account today
to team up with with a company like zell
where they actually care about the
community they talk that talk but they
also back it up and they walk that walk
and presenting new opportunities to
these young black women
that's everything what did you think
about your mural though
wow
y'all gonna have me get choked up
it's really dope thank you look at that
piping up y'all got me out here
i see myself in them and i hope they see
themselves and me